can't beat properly home-cooked popcorn
start off with just a touch of oil in
there
as it lightly starts to smoke
corn in so now get your lid
never leave it far away from you
sounds like it's raining it's not so
it's popcorn canals trying to
pop out boom
delicious just a little shake of the pan
get it going
and then lift that lid at your apparel
we see it's a
very exciting pan in there
and when all that little pitter patter
stops you know your popcorn is cooked
nice you could eat it fresh from the pan
but i've got another plan
i'm gonna make a salted caramel popcorn
start off with
your sugar into the hot pan never stir a
caramel otherwise it crystallizes
it's a salted caramel so a nice pinch of
salt
in there as well now once you've got it
to a really nice dark
caramel flavor stir in your butter very
carefully caramel is very very hot
half a teaspoon of bicarbonate of soda
kickstarts the reaction that gives the
caramel a honeycomb flavor
mix that in you'll see it
reacting almost like a large crunchy
in the bottom of your bowl now the gas
is off
and that camera has a nice dark rich
flavor now pour in the popcorn to coat
it with that incredible caramel
give that a good mix it's that easy
and it's gonna taste amazing lay that
nice and flat
once that cools down it becomes nice and
brittle we've got that nice salted
caramel flavor
which just takes popcorn to a complete
dim level whilst the popcorn cools down
it's onto my prawn tostada wonderful
prawns
i'm gonna marinate them first with a
little bit of garlic
nice and fine and don't worry if you
can't slice thinly just
get a little crater and grate the garlic
nice and fine as well nice pinch
of chili flakes over your prawn garlic
in
salt pepper
and olive oil give that a really nice
little mix whilst the prawns marinade
i'm gonna knock up a salad this is a
really nice sort of
light fragrant salad radishes topped and
tailed
and then into quarters cherry tomatoes
halved
spring onions sliced and seasoned
and then just to liven things up a
little bit of chili in there
and slice them on an angle
now the avocado cut in half
give that a little twist so you just go
down
and down and down carefully with your
knife turn it around
go down and down and down and then
you take your spoon and you've got your
diced avocado
coming out already now baby gem lettuce
half then shred freshly squeezed lime
juice
and a little drizzle of olive oil
tostada is a
classic mexican style
open tortilla so that lime complements
it
beautifully lastly roughly chopped
coriander and give it a mix
that is the perfect base for our tostada
the salad's ready now for the prawns and
don't be afraid of getting the pan
nice and hot teaspoon
of olive oil in
anything less than that sizzle when you
put that first prawn in there
don't put them in keep them nice and
flat
make sure you've got all that marinade
in there as well watch them change color
rapidly i'd rather cook them quicker
in a hotter pan and slower in a colder
pan
the difference in taste is night and day
the prawns will take just two minutes to
cook through
lime juice just over the top nice
toss them over the lime
these are corn tortilla quite robust
and it's a kind of base that doesn't
disintegrate hot pan
in it's a dry pan so
that corn tortilla goes nice and crispy
on the outside
[Music]
look crispy shell to build them
generous with the salad that base will
stay nice and crisp
next with your prawns i like to keep the
tails
in to the center and lay the round
part of the prawn on the outside and
there we have
a delicious yeah very humble prawn
tostada
followed by my superb salty caramel
popcorn
beautiful
[Music]
prawn tostadas and salty caramel popcorn
vibrant irresistible smelling dishes
you'll want to dive into
big and bold i was living in france i
stayed there for three years
once twice a week i treated myself to
the most amazing
bold breakfast and it started off with
these beauties here murgays
cheap but incredibly tasty start off
with a nice hot pan
mug is in it's a very spicy sausage
doesn't need any help doesn't even need
chili just a touch
of salt and pepper
you can smell the spice they're starting
to release all that wonderful
oil that flavor in there
add a couple of cloves i'll finely slice
garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color
takes on this nice dark rich golden
color
now take a look with the heat out with
the parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavour during cooking
but the leaves should always be added
just before serving to give
maximum colour and fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing all right
beautiful now
take your quests on they're literally 24
hours old so they're
crispy on the outside and just slice off
the lid this recipe is a great way to
use up
any leftover croissants from the day
before i used to cringe when i
saw the french cooks throw away
croissants i used to cry thinking
oh my god any idea what you're throwing
away in terms of flavor
whatever you do do not wipe out that pan
dunk
your croissants mopping up all that
amazing flavor
and caramelizing the inside
for that beautiful and don't forget the
lids
and then get your thumbs and go inside
the croissant
all i want to do now is just create a
little pocket
and just manipulate the crescent now
this is where it gets exciting
mix up the capers the garlic and
sausages look at the color
of that wonderful delicious flavored
oil now some cheese but not just
any cheese fontina cheese is like the
number one cheese for grilling
and because it's a very rich cheese you
shave it
thinner than you would a white truffle
but it gives a really nice saltiness
and a light smoky flavour
salt place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds on the grill
here we go nice
crisp packed full of flavor
now top them and that for me it's almost
like being back in paris
except this time i don't have to share
them with the french
my ultimate big and bold breakfast
murgies
and fontina stuffed croissants a great
way to start the day
[Music]
jack hi my gonna help with some pickling
please oh definitely
no you love pickles right love pickles
um favorite pickle what is it
i like pickled onions we're going to do
pickled celery mm-hmm
it's a nice little snack and great for
plum ones great for salads first thing
we need to pick the celery for me so you
see where the next one's going to be
it's in there
yeah okay i'll figure it out but i'm
hungry today is this all we're having
for dinner
jack come on i wouldn't do that to you
you know that there's more coming
now because we're pickling it we want to
sort of make it
look a little bit more attractive so we
go around like that
okay on an angle so when you pick all
the food does it
does it preserve it it's exactly what it
does but also gives it a really nice
salty
soury flavour yeah okay now splash of
water
and then with the sugar nice okay so
gotta bring that up to the bowl
and sort of create almost like a little
syrup
yeah okay little teaspoon of peppercorns
in mustard seeds in
quite generous on the mustard seeds that
gives a bit of sort of spice now those
you must know cloves excellent
cloves in now touch of salt
no okay so from there white wine vinegar
now in order for all that to actually
pickle you need to boil it so by boiling
it
okay it brings all the ingredients
together it fuses all the spices
and helps cook the celery
have a little taste
nice nice see i put some hairs on your
chest yes it will
look boom it's working already now see
nice wine vinegar
right celery's ready yeah okay let's
walk to the ball now
turn that off now from there
start placing the celery into that jar
so when you pick other foods can you use
that same
recipe exactly that 100
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off mm-hmm okay now
put them in there so can we eat this
straight away when it's in here do you
know what
as soon as it's cooled down you can
definitely eat that straight away i
can't wait to dig into it at dinner are
they delicious
yes we'll leave that to cool down our
pickles are ready
and cooling now to marinate the chicken
when you fried chicken traditionally
it's always gonna be done with the dark
meat the brown meat
so you've got that nice sort of uh drum
here
and this bit that thigh cooking on the
bone as well keeps it even more
moist so first things first salt pepper
please
from there famous buttermilk buttermilk
in it's brilliant for marinating the
chicken
if you can put this buttermilk over your
chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of
really relax the chicken and puts a
really nice sort of
creamy soury flavor in there so might
stick that in the fridge for us please
and we'll start the dolce de leche
biscuits nice
the argentinians call these shortbreads
alfa jorge
and they're the favorite sweet treat on
the streets of buenos aires
they're light crumbly shortbread
biscuits sandwiched with gloriously
golden
caramel dolce de leche sauce
for the shortbread beat together
softened butter
granulated sugar and beat until light
and fluffy
add one egg
[Music]
slice vanilla pots scrape out the seeds
add to the mix and beat again
plain flour corn flour
and baking powder then fold the mixture
together
using floured hands roll into small
balls
flatten into discs and place on a baking
tray
[Music]
chill for 10 minutes until firm to touch
then simply bake for 10 to 12 minutes or
until pale golden
once cooled sandwich two biscuits
together with a caramelly dolce de leche
sauce
[Music]
finish with a dusting of icing sugar
[Music]
delicious
my dessert and pickles are ready the
buttermilk should have worked its magic
on the chicken
all that's left is to fry it now we're
gonna
roll the chicken out of the buttermilk
into the flour so that's why it gets
nice and crispy and blistery on the
outside
okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat
yes this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice and this
is smoked paprika so that gives it a
little bit of sort of uh
maybelline yeah yeah spice that's right
a little bit of heat and this one my
favorites
what's that cayenne pepper that's right
again slightly spicy
but the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally are used a
lot in the steaks onion powder garlic
powder just
run your fingers through that please
cool i'm gonna get the pan on
now two centimetres of oil
this is a really good mix for fish as
well mm-hmm goujons
fighting a nice spicy texture
helps fish so first thing is we just
shake off some of the buttermilk
lay that down yes okay really important
to get them covered completely
okay in the flour yeah okay so
i love fried chicken do you now
lift that up there first one and you
place it in there
away from you off you go nice and gently
good
and lay away good if any stage you think
the oil
is getting too hot yeah just add a touch
of cold oil in there
or turn off the gas good gently fry the
chicken for 25 to 30 minutes
or until cooked through now very
carefully
turn them over please yeah cool
can we have this every day jack fried
chicken every day
no definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so
once every three weeks yeah sounds great
to me
yeah now off with the gas
okay yeah paper ready okay onto the
paper
sell them
i love fried chicken i'm telling you i'm
pretty sure i love it morning
look here's the best bit
delicious now fried chicken
pickles if you pick up um dolce de leche
cakes we are ready bud
very nice that's good delicious uncle
mummy wow
tilly phoebe rum divine dolce de leche
biscuits
my pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken
a soulful street food feast if there
ever was one